[Applause]  well this guard up there I guess  Oh oh my god Randy Rhoads ladies and  gentlemen the kitchen don't know  I mean she has her gear on ashy and  serving yourself in this that what she  may be she has that off that's that  right interview I don't know well she is  the chief she'll arrest arrest she does  guys don't don't look confuse and don't  look at me like I like you when I said  that you Kylie and you Britain United  when I said that each of you could  possibly win this match I meant it from  the bottom of my heart I meant that and  when I said to all of you that this  triple threat match could be a great  mesh i 100% meant that but I've ran into  a problem the problem is I don't want a  great match I want to match that is  awesome  [Applause]  she'd buy that gym  [Music]  [Applause]  [Applause]  has become a cruiser way  you